hello hello hello you're watching scp
explained and today we've got an offer
you simply can't refuse the very latest
in anomalous self-improvement technology
which the scp foundation calls scp-212
but we much prefer to call it the
improver believe us when we say this
miraculous device will change your life
you'll never be the same after a run
with the improver it'll make you fitter
healthier better
not convinced don't worry just sit back
and let us sell you the dream here's
some unpleasant news you're going to die
no matter how healthy you are right now
there will inevitably come a day when
your lungs stop pumping your ticker
stops ticking and all those delightful
little synapses in your brain stop
sending electrical and chemical signals
to and fro what a bummer why would you
want to be dead you can't do stuff when
you're dead and it's all because
everyone is eventually betrayed by the
very things currently keeping them alive
those pesky squishy failable organs but
thanks to the improver getting stuck
with the organs you were born with is a
problem of yesteryear no matter what
those lousy circus tell you the flesh is
unreliable metal and plastic on the
other hand
that's built to last bleeding hearts
talk a lot about quality of life but
what really matters is quality of life
and if you're strong enough that's what
the improver a state-of-the-art piece of
medical technology will give you don't
look so afraid you replace your phone
every year you replace your laptop every
few years so why get all sentimental
about needing to trade in your old liver
eyes limbs or skin for the new model or
in the words of another great
businessman why be you when you can be
new
not convinced let us tell you about the
incredible features that the improver
has to offer i'm talking three top of
the line fully opposable plastic and
steel autonomous medical limbs that's
industry lingo for robot arms that work
on their own with 500 count on 500
different attachments but i know what
you're thinking 500 attachments where am
i gonna find the room for all that scp
explained to which we say don't worry
about it due to its spatially anomalous
properties the improver is able to store
all these attachments within its arms
without any additional space concerns
and hey i see that nervous look in your
eye you're worried about the operating
costs right but don't worry there's no
need the improver is completely
self-powered with no discernible power
source and you know the thing is safe
because the scp foundation has given it
the safe object class sure that
technically doesn't mean it's not
dangerous but it does mean it won't
sprout legs and walk off if you leave it
to your own devices am i right folks so
you're looking at a long-term investment
with the three-year warranty and an
endorsement from the fabulous folks at
the church of the broken god you just
can't argue with these deals my friends
we even offer competitive rates against
marshall carter and dark but hey we're
not trying to pull the wool over your
eyes here you're a smart consumer we
know that you know the actual financial
cost is only one layer of the overall
cost time and training is also of course
a factor but we've got some good news
for you sunshine
the improver is 100 user-friendly no
setup no mess no problem no trying to
interpret poorly written instructions or
watch batted out youtube tech tutorials
where the guy just will not get to the
point the improver operates itself it
may be a piece of hyper-advanced
anomalous technology but it's easier to
use than most wireless printers am i
right am i right the steps to using the
improver are so simple a monkey could do
it just step within a 1.5 meter range of
the machine and it will do the rest
you'll feel your troubles melt away as
the powerful mechanical arms grab you
and restrain you against the floor
you'll be subjected to a brief relaxing
scan where the improver will determine
exactly what needs to be changed about
your fragile human physiology and then
before you know it surgery will commence
warning scp explained is not liable for
any excruciating pain caused by the
improver medical sedatives and
anesthetics are sold separately the
consumer is responsible for their own
pain relief when using the approver
second warning the consumer is also
responsible for their own blood
transfusions when using the improver
neither the improver nor scp explained
is liable for any blood loss while using
the improver your blood your problem now
with those tiny little caveats out of
the way we carry on telling you just how
fantastic the improver is sure flesh
worshiping circus losers and haters will
tell you that it has a mortality rate of
around 47 but we prefer to look on the
bright side and focus on its excellent
53 survival rate rest assured the odds
are still very much in your favor when
you use the improver and doesn't adding
a slight risk to the equation just make
the whole process even more exciting we
certainly think it does and in the
reasonably likely event that you survive
using the improver the benefits will
vastly outweigh the costs it can do
incredible things like lining your
joints with graphite replacing your
nasty flesh organs with more powerful
artificial ones adding new or duplicate
organs replacing those unreliable teeth
with serrated steel blades and so much
more is there anything this absolute
marvel of a machine can't do doctors
hate it the improver is here to fix
every aspect of your life and health
with its simple anomalous tricks it even
has a special sealant for wound closing
that no medical professional on earth
has access to what is it exactly well if
we told you i'm afraid we'd have to kill
you it's a trade secret
[Laughter]
you'd have to be crazy not to want the
improver in your home but if for some
crazy reason you still need to be
convinced let's look at some real
success stories of the improver in
action stir eight from scp foundation
testing logs listen close and soon
you'll see the improver literally makes
satisfied customers the foundation put a
28 year old african-american agent into
the improver of his own volition he
replaced his boring lower jaw bone with
a super dense ceramic jaw with ceramic
blades instead of teeth it also removed
his spine and replaced it with a
synthetic polymer which was easily
affixed to the base of his skull and at
no extra charge it even coated his rib
cage and pelvis with a thin layer of
ceramic before removing his lungs eyes
and liver for cleaning and replacement
that's right cleaning the improver can
remove organs and through a patented
cleaning process remove genetic defects
and allow them to appear younger and
healthier than generic brandex organs
this agent has since returned to active
duty and is even better at his job all
thanks to the improver looking good out
there champ a 42 year old british
foundation researcher was submitted for
testing on the improver it replaced his
teeth with sleek super dense ceramic
reinstated his inefficient feet and
replaced them with a complex latticework
covered in sticky pads that would let
him climb on any surface and hold up to
225 kilograms of weight it also took out
and cleaned a huge number of his organs
removed his bone marrow and replaced it
with blue synthetic gel much more
effective we assure you and inserted a
few random bits of metal into his brain
at no extra cost sadly this researcher
passed away during the bone marrow
removal process but for all we know that
could easily just be a coincidence next
came an agent co-named a.a who had
suffered a pretty severe accident at
work losing all his limbs one of his
eyes a few of his organs and suffering a
pretty dramatic head injury namely
taking a piece of circuit board to the
brain during an explosion he was given
over to the improver seeing as he didn't
really have much to lose in terms of
physical integrity but seeing that it's
an amazing piece of groundbreaking
technology the improver never takes the
obvious option it gave a.a a chemical
that forced him into a coma and then
properly integrated the circuit board
into his brain it continues to spread
and assimilate more of his brain matter
while he's in a comatose state though
when he awakens with a much more
efficient brain he'll probably be
incredibly grateful to the improver for
helping him like this and it's not just
people with severe injuries that the
improver can lend three helping robotic
hands too it's also the victims of
severe and even anomalous diseases take
victims of scp-217 a rather horrific and
painful disease that mechanizes the
entire body until the sufferers aren't
really themselves anymore a normal
uninspired scp foundation researcher may
look at someone like this and see a lost
cause but with the help of the improver
no cause is lost a d-class in the
advanced stages of the disease was run
through the machine and while the exact
details of what it did to him are
another trade secret it's safe to say he
was truly fighting fit when he came out
on the other side we mean that literally
he easily escaped containment and
overpowered two heavily armed guards
before taking the lives of several
members of foundation staff before being
captured and terminated sometime later
you can argue with those incredible
results folks next came a 26 year old
scp foundation researcher who due to an
unfortunate brush with a less wonderful
and beneficial anomaly had been rendered
completely blind however when he was
brought into the grasp of the improver
it immediately set to work on solving
the doctor's little problem it removed
his two non-functioning eyes and made
the interesting creative choice of
widening the two cavities in his head so
they met in the middle and formed one
huge cavity for a single large sensory
organ this cavity was then filled with
large metal spikes resembling hair which
are far more interesting than typical
eyes during the improvers delicate
medical procedures the scientists
inexplicably entered a state of visible
distress and began repeating the phrase
it tastes all wrong at this point the
metal cilia in the scientist's single
large cavity began to grow expanding
through the roof of the cavity and into
the subject's brain killing him we want
to specify that scp explained and the
improver are in no way responsible for
this unfortunate incident it's entirely
the researcher's fault for setting off
his own metal eye cavity cilia before we
bring this anomalous infomercial to an
end and of course before you immediately
grab your credit card and buy your own
improver device we want to sneak a few
more disclaimers under the wire for
starters the improver doesn't work on
animals when a rat was used as a test
subject the device attempted to modify
the rat into a bipedal being removing
the majority of its organs and replacing
it with white paste so if your pet rat
gets sick just uh take it to the vet
instead the improver also doesn't work
on corpses it may be a miraculous piece
of technology but uh
it's not a literal miracle worker folks
one freshly executed d-class was
presented to the improver and instead of
operating on him the improver cut open
his stomach and instead began
constructing something out of metal he
had consumed the night prior to his
death a seafood dinner the broken
crustacean parts were then constructed
into a bioluminescent lobster-like
creature so if you're planning on
bringing someone back from the dead
we're afraid you're going to need to
take up necromancy instead but if you
haven't died yet and you're looking to
improve yourself then you cannot invest
in a better product than the improver
the one problem is that the only known
prototype of the improver is currently
locked in an scp foundation containment
site so getting your hands on these
three special alarms may cost you your
life what who said attaining perfection
would be easy now go check out scp-914
the clockworks and scp-001 the broken
god oraboro cycle for more frightening
anomalous machines i'm your disembodied
narrator telling you to be safe i'm
watching you while you sleep